do you miss
your brother your dad
like i mean i'm
for me at the moment i'm here yeah focus
on these guys and these families and
giving everything i can 120 to them to
make sure that they have the experience
of a lifetime yeah that's my progress
here prince harry seemingly not ready to
talk about his relationship with his
father prince charles and brother prince
william and then when i leave here i get
back and my focus is my family who i
miss massively you do like that of
course i do two two little people you
know the duke of sussex opens up to
today's hoda copy during a trip to the
netherlands for the invictus games their
chat comes on the heels of his first
visit back to the uk with his wife
meghan markle since stepping down from
their royal duties in 2020. he's made
this detour to the uk very much wanting
to
meet with some of his family and he was
very keen to see his grandmother is very
keen to see his father and that he is
hoping that these talks will be the
beginning of
a thought in what up until now has been
a very icy relationship and that visit
included quality time well spent with
his grandmother queen elizabeth it was
it was just so nice to see her you know
i'm grateful we always she's always got
a great sense of humor with me and i'm
just making sure that she's you know
protected and got the right people well
you make her laugh that's what she
always says
did you do it again yes yeah i did both
megan i had tea with her so it was
really nice to catch up with her but
when it comes to the duke of sussex's
relationship with his father and brother
that's still a work in progress you'll
recall in march 2021 the duke and
duchess gave a tell-all interview to
oprah winfrey which included bombshell
claims about racism and friction within
the royal family fast forward to 2022
and it seems harry isn't ready to talk
about the fallout just yet do you miss
your brother your dad
look i mean i'm
for me at the moment i'm here yeah focus
on these guys and these families and
giving everything i can 120 to them to
make sure that they have the experience
of a lifetime yeah that's my focus here
but we know things are seemingly
improving behind closed doors ahead of
the invictus games harry met with his
father i've spoken to a source close to
the prince of wales who said that while
it was slightly tense it was also very
lovely for the prince of wales to see
his son he hasn't seen him for over a
year and the feeling is that this has
almost been a bit of an icebreaker that
first conversation difficult
conversation has been had
and they're hoping this will pave the
way for further discussions and
conversations and perhaps a thoring of
what has been an icy relationship up
until now and it turns out prince harry
also wants to sort things out with his
brother but with some help
harry i'm told suggested perhaps that
they might get some sort of a mediator
in on these talks to make some progress
it was something that he has suggested
to his father he's made it very clear
that he he wants to sort things out he
wants things to be improved i would
imagine that that idea of wanting a
mediator is probably more to do with him
and william whose relationship really is
you know at a bit of a crossroads they
haven't spoken for many months they're
not close at the moment it has been very
very difficult that sort of hope of a
rapprochement i think is is much further
off for william and harry far more so
than it is for harry and his father
[Music]